in the pancreas tiny scatters of cells
called the islets of langerhans are
composed of alpha cells which produces
glucagon that come with glycogen from
the liver into glucose there are also
beta cells which produces insulin that
converts glucose to glycogen insulin
production is stimulated by hormones and
as increments such as glucagon-like
peptide one also known as glp-1 insulin
resistance causes poor response on the
liver which may deliver needs warrant in
order to function with the failure of
the beta cells to keep up with the
insulin demand glucose builds up in the
bloodstream and this causes diabetes as
well as other health problems now the
symptoms of type 2 diabetes this
includes excessive thirst frequent or
increased urination on a regular basis
excessive hunger fatigue blurry vision
and source of cuts that will not heal
one of the treatment methods of type 2
diabetes is the uses of drugs that
inhibit dpp-4 dpp-4 or dipeptidyl
peptidase-4 is an enzyme expressed on
the surface of most all types and
rapidly breaks down in cretons such as
glp-1 thus this enzyme is inhibited
including production will increase
stimulating insulin production side
effects of these drugs include heart
failure
hypersensitivity skin reactions severe
joint pain Masco pharyngitis headache
and nausea another human method of type
2 diabetes is the injection of
ingredient analogues these mimic Egerton
behavior but cannot be deactivated by a
dpp-4 and hence more insulin can be
produced one such example is excellent
for a naturally occurring capsid found
in lizard venom the set of bpp mediated
inactivation for excellence for contains
and glycine rather than
alanine just found in human GOP 1 so the
DCP 4 is not able to deactivate
excrement for lastly another treatment
method is the use of glucose kinase
inhibitors with cost services an enzyme
which breaks down starch into
monosaccharides like glucose for the
body to absorb with inhibitors
inhibiting Mukasa days sarch is not able
to be broken down and eliminated through
excretion instead
hence blood glucose levels will not rise
eliminating the need to produce more
insulin